okay so but obviously if you're like e
coli i wouldn't count that the same as
regular food so
bringing this back to how we start this
conversation how does this even come out
how often do you normally get ill
that's how that's counting food
personally
once a year maybe okay okay including
food poisoning
oh i think that's exponentially
it could
that could be like how many flaming
cheetos have i eaten that yeah how risky
we talking
last year was like what four four times
yes yeah that's three of them with food
poisoning though right so one
so like this
one like this so like aside from this
time the last time i got ill was
literally like two years before this i
don't get ill often very rarely i very
rarely get ill as well like i i very i
very rarely get ill to the point where i
cannot
like i kind of walk yeah yeah i i i need
to actually like take a take a rest and
take a break because i feel like i don't
know i feel like my body
obviously this is all talking [ __ ] i
feel like my body even if like this
whole episode's [ __ ] yeah because
like there's been there's been points
where sydney has been like [ __ ]
cocked out in bed with a high fever and
all that [ __ ] and i get like a mild
cough and that's just that's just it and
yeah and she's conked out for two days
and i'm just like
um how are you doing honey how are you
doing honey this is why you need to get
good yeah this one will scare me as well
because i'm like when i'm around that's
right that's how this all comes from
yeah when i'm around sick people i get
way more scared oh yeah it freaks me out
i don't know why is this is this like a
human uh reaction that we have that
we're like scared about it's i think
it's pretty natural to be afraid of it
yeah yeah i i feel like that's a big
natural human reaction because yeah you
just you are adverse to getting ill you
know you're here you are adversely
people are sick people die there it's
like why would you enjoy your a place
where people die back when i had him uh
when i got back when i had it when it's
genetic what the [ __ ]
um
so i had to go to the hospital a lot
when i was a kid because i had to get my
blood tested like every uh three months
or something or every six months or
something like that and far too often
for my liking yeah um and i hated it
because i had to like sit there for like
four hours get a test wait get another
test and get results and stuff and then
the whole time i was just surrounded by
like
very very ill people and it was always
just like really scary it's like an
eight-year-old and didn't like keep
growing up and just keep seeing this and
that oh yeah oh uh oh and all the
offices of like the doctors have are
always like really cluttered they're
really messy and i was like i was like
ah oh i think i think the one thing i
hate about the hospital the most is the
smell yeah the smell yeah it's like the
smell of a hospital is just like oh it's
like
it's hard to explain that there was yeah
there was
you know like like i said when when
you're ill and when i was ill things
just smell and taste different you know
yeah of course naturally and it it
[ __ ] sucks but like when you go to a
hospital for some reason you get that
same smell where it's just like man
everything just smells stale you know
yeah
it's the stale smell like like the magic
like the color has been like taken out
of everything you know
like that's how i feel when i'm ill i
don't know it just it just feels like it
just feels like life gets gets like a
black and white filter to be put onto it
do you do you like the smell of the
dentist no
because i know people who love the smell
of the dead what is the smell of the
dentist oh sweeney todd what
it's like the smell of like uh
i don't know what it's it's the smell of
uh like
i don't know how do you how do you
describe the small group i don't i don't
go bro i'm british we don't go to the
dentist
i don't know i i don't smell the dentist
often i'm couched in and out i want to
get out there soon it smells like clean
teeth but in like the worst way possible
well it smells like chemicals it's the
only way yeah i guess i never i never
really thought about it it smells like
like hand sanitizer yeah like that kind
of fresh kind of like
yeah because like you know when you
think of like say you know something
that's clean right like you know like
scented hand sanitizer or whatever right
or like you know febreze or whatever
right usually it's like oh that's a good
smell like that's like a refreshing
smell but like hospitals and dentists
for me are just like it's clean but
something no the hospital and dentist is
not different to me like no they're very
very like i feel they're in like the
same like category of like it's clean
but it's not it's not like a good clean
it's like too clean
where it's like nothing's here anymore
levels of clean like it's sterilized is
a good word yeah so it's it's sterile
which i hope they are
i would very much hope that they are
sterile you know
the smell yeah
apparently dentist smell of clove oil
and tooth dust
clove oil and tooth dust what the [ __ ]
yeah it just smells like chlorine
no
it has like a faint chlorine
maybe maybe the dentist
i don't know if it's like what they're
shoving in your mouth
i don't know i don't know if they're
like next to a pool or whatever but like
it smells like chlorine how often do you
guys go to the dentist i tried to like
twice a year just it just was like a
checkup
did you like put it in your because like
as british culture
british culture we we don't go to the
dentist like a lot and i only really
started going uh actually like we i
would normally only go to the dentist
before when i'd go to like asia and then
yeah like because like dentists were
actually like really much cheaper i am i
am before the all the british tooth uh
jokes in the comments now
but like
did do you have like a schedule of like
oh it's been like three months or six
months
i was like where are you yeah they say i
think they say when you're an adult you
should go at least two or three times a
year as for like a checkup i don't
[ __ ] know well like you know because
the good thing with the dentist is that
like even if you don't have like the
cavity or you're not hurting anywhere
like they'll at least just like [ __ ]
clean your teeth yeah i hate them
clearing my teeth though that was that
drill so loud oh the water like pressure
thing right yeah yeah yeah in japan in
japan it's horrible no like to me i
think the worst feeling is like getting
a filling and like i don't know just
like have you got a feeling before
i've gotten one before right and i don't
know that like that experience as a kid
just scarred me for life right because
just like i don't know what it is about
just
like just hearing the drill and just
like not being able to see
what they are doing to your mouth and
just like do you want do you want to see
do you want tv i i don't know i i don't
know what's scarier right because you
know it's like i need to see this in 4k
i think it can be arranged actually
no because like just i i i it's like
that feeling of just when they hit like
a nerve ending for just a second yeah
i feel that in my nightmares you know
[ __ ] i like ever since i heard felt
that i was a kid the first time i just
that put me off going to the dentist
ever again yeah um the worst the worst
for me is when you hear the drill sound
but it's like deep in your ear so it
sounds like it's in your ear and yeah i
hate it because it just sounds like
someone's just getting into your ear
like that i had like uh like a night
mold made you know like when you go to
bed you wear like one of those plastic
guards yeah i've got that
my dad speaks english too
i don't know it's really it was really
annoying to sleep with for a long time i
couldn't sleep with it in yeah it took
it took me about a week to get used to
yeah i woke up drooling everywhere with
it yeah yeah that's that's a normal
experience yeah
i think i think i didn't start snoring
until i started wearing my mouth guard
because it literally forced you to be to
be a mouth breather when you sleep right
because
was like you don't really need it but
it's good to just prevent prevent uh
dennis was just trying to [ __ ] you over
well i was like 300 bucks so i'm sure
they were like yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah you need this you need this they
were like they were like yeah i do
you're grinding your teeth is an issue
but it might be so we can get a night
guard done if you just want to be
careful and we can out and i was like oh
uh sure
yeah and then they did it and then i
just really didn't like it so i just
stopped using it because i grinded my
teeth as well but my doctor was like if
you don't have this guard your bottom
teeth are really going to disappear i
was like oh really great please give me
the mouth guard yeah like i i didn't
really know about it until uh until i
started getting like jaw problems so
like i think like in my mid to late 20s
i started like getting jaw problems
where it felt like my
like it's sometimes i'd wake up and
something will like feel off or like
slightly dislocated or yeah
yeah like like i never i i didn't know
that it was an issue until i started
getting the issue and then uh i went to
my dentist and you're like uh yeah you
grind your teeth a [ __ ] ton and uh you
need to wear a mouth guard because uh
your your bite is going to get like more
and more deformed
appointment because i forgot to reply to
that email like yeah yeah
i hated it when they did the mold thing
right they put like all that that gunk
in you yeah like the putty thing right
yeah it was so confusing figuring out
how to breathe for a second where i was
like wait [ __ ] my mouth is completely
like covered with this gunk how do i
breathe without my teeth it feels so
weird i wonder if that's how it feels
when you have like dentures i don't know
just like not having teeth it felt
really strange
also i remember that they were like do
whatever you do do not swallow right now
and then i've never had an urge to
swallow more of my life
is that a challenge
they're like blasting [ __ ] in your mouth
trying to clean up something like that
all i can think about is swallowing this
weird liquid that smells like apples i
want to do it jojo fans be awake
that's the jojo fight
he thinks i won't swallow but i will
swallow the poison
next thing you'll say is don't swallow
it
[Laughter]
that's true
it's awful i don't like dentists i don't
think anyone likes the dentist if they
do i don't like i don't think anyone
likes the hospital as well
um
well yes yeah
kids want to play on the the free ps2
that they have there
he talked about this
it used to be me
yeah i used to like it but then the
gamecube controls are robbed yeah yeah i
wish i went to your hospital because my
hospital didn't have that [ __ ] at all